ravi de revoir moi aussi mais comment tu
vas retrouver
regarder quels
bhanji livre moi ton amical m
antony green et à tes trousses on s'est
pas vu toutes ces années
je n'ai pas l'intention de le laisser
s'en sortir
on dirait bien que tu as eu un excellent
entraîneur
donc tu veux te battre contre anthony
non tous les deux on va le combattre
arrête de te cacher comme ça cet
adorable brunette s'est qui faisait ma
fille tu as quoi elle te tient en otage
non non et arrête de pointer ce pistolet
sur notre avis tu es d'accord
temple
je travaille oui
ça peut être utile
petite soeur
tu es là
on va jouer
honnêtement
j'ai vu bien pire
on va vers ça à l'ancienne
c'est parti
[Musique]
il reste
j'espère que non
[Musique]